from beloved Art House Classics to
forgettable horror revivals these
franchises couldn't wait a full 12
months before releasing their next
installments
there are sticklers out there who will
tell you that the man with no name the
strong quiet anti-hero played by Clint
Eastwood and Sergio Leone's Trilogy of
landmark westerns does have a name in
fact he has three names in 1964 is a
fist full of dollars wherein our man
pits the Rival factions of a small
Frontier Town against one another his
name is Joe in 1965's for a few dollars
more however his name is monco and he's
a bounty hunter who joins forces with a
rival to take down a Mexican bank robber
finally in the 1966 semi prequel The
Good the Bad and the Ugly he is called
Blondie as he races against a ruthless
mercenary and a Wily Bandit to find a
stash of Confederate gold you might have
noticed that Eastwood isn't really the
same character in each of these films
nor were they released in the same year
after the Spaghetti Westerns made waves
in Italy and across Europe United
Artists released them all in 1967. the
first two in January and May and The
Good The Bad and The ugly in December
the artwork for the American releases
emphasized that the films were all of a
piece and introduced the moniker of the
man with no name in an attempt to bind
the films more closely together the
marketing campaign worked like
gangbusters and all these years later
the three films are still packaged
together as the man with no name trilogy
the circumstances that led to both Roger
Moore and Sean Connery playing James
Bond in 1983 are complicated and go back
several decades earlier in the 50s Bond
author Ian Fleming collaborated with
writer Kevin mcclory on an unused 007
film script that eventually became the
novel Thunderball later in 1961 mcclory
sued Fleming and eventually was awarded
a story credit on the novel's 1965 film
adaptation as well as ownership of
certain story elements most notably the
terrorist organization Specter and its
cat-loving leader Ernst blofeld mcclory
spent more than a decade in various
legal battles with United Artists in
order to make his own film and in 1983
he finally got his chance Never Say
Never Again produced for Warner Brothers
is essentially a remake of Thunderball
with Specter once again holding the
world hostage with a pair of nuclear
warheads its Ace in the Hole of course
is Sean Connery returning to the role
all he made famous for the first time
since 1971's diamonds are forever
hope we're gonna have some gratuitous
sex and violence I certainly hope so too
the film also boasts solid action scenes
from director Irvin kirschner and a
great performance from Barbara Carrera
as the scenery chewing fim fatal Fatima
blush meanwhile the official Bond
franchise kept chugging along in the
same year with the very silly octopussy
which has double07 played by Roger Moore
in his sixth appearance foiling a rogue
Soviet General and an exiled Afghan
Prince with the help of some beautiful
circus trained Jewel thieves
in 1984 the schlock Meister is at troma
entertainment scored a genuine hit with
the superhero parody the Toxic Avenger
in which wimpy janitor Melvin junko is
dumped into a vat of toxic waste and
emerges as a Monster who dedicates
himself to fighting crime five years
later the first superhero from New
Jersey returned in the Toxic Avenger
part 2. in the sequel toxi travels to
Japan to find his long-lost father
leaving trumaville helpless to the
machinations of the super villain
Corporation apocalypse Incorporated
thankfully though he comes back to save
the day after all if Tromaville was
destroyed there would never be a Toxic
Avenger part 3.
the original cut of part 2 reportedly
ran close to four hours so trauma
Mastermind Lloyd Kaufman did the only
sensible thing and made two movies out
of it part 3 subtitled The Last
Temptation of toxic picks up at the
second half of the story when toxi
returns from Japan and runs apocalypse
ink out of town he finds that he did his
job too well as there are no more bad
guys left in Tromaville to defeat in
need of a job to pay for a medical
operation that could restore his blind
girlfriend's sight toxy does the
unthinkable and takes a job with
apocalypse Inc but will success in the
trappings of Yuppie life spoil our lumpy
protector and is the chairman of the
evil Corporation even more evil than
previously advertised the toxic Avengers
Saga has to be seen to be believed
polish filmmaker Christoph kislovsky's
three colors Trilogy consists of three
films that have mostly unrelated
characters and plots but are united in
theme and intended as a singular
experience after all when U.S critics
were preparing their best of lists for
1994 the films took up one ranking spot
instead of three the title of each
installment refers to the three colors
of the French flag and the ideals they
represent blue for Liberty white for
equality and red for Fraternity blue
arrived in late 1993 starring Juliet
pinoche as a wife and mother who is
cruelly liberated by the death of her
husband and young child struck none by
grief she strikes up several unexpected
connections as she struggles to move
forward white and red were both released
in 1994. the former concerns an unhappy
man who after getting a divorce from his
wife smuggles himself back home to
Poland inside a large suitcase meanwhile
red follows a model living in Geneva who
connects with a retired judge after she
accidentally hits his dog with her car
each film has the lean efficiency and
finely tuned irony of a good short story
and none of them turn out quite as
expect
no other single film did more to Define
sci-fi in the 21st century than the
wachowski's 1999 hit the Matrix the
dystopian martial arts superhero mashup
coined a whole new cinematic language
and its impact can still be seen in its
Aesthetics special effects technology
and perhaps unfortunately in real life
today a sequel was all but guaranteed
but the task of living up to fans
massive expectations was daunting four
years after Neo flew through the air at
the end of the first film The wachowskis
Returned with not one sequel but two The
Matrix Reloaded in May 2003 and The
Matrix Revolutions six months later the
films promised everything a sequel
should have like bigger and better
action set pieces and more of the
characters we loved from the first film
along with a few answers to the many
questions posed by its increasingly
convoluted mythology but while the
sequels delivered the goods when it came
to the action the highway chase and
reloaded remains in all timer decades
later it fared less well when trying to
untangle its own dorm room philosophical
inquiries revolutions was largely seen
as a disappointing camper to the trilogy
and when Lana Wachowski returned 18
years later to helm the reboot the
Matrix resurrections she crafted a
proper ending as much as she did a new
beginning
that's the thing about stories
they never really end do they
the 2000 Canadian horror flick Ginger
Snaps took on the werewolf genre through
the lens of female adolescents in
puberty as spooky teen sisters Ginger
and Bridget work to control Ginger's
violent monthly urges after she is
bitten by a werewolf the 2004 sequel
Ginger Snaps two Unleashed takes a page
from A Nightmare on Elm Street part 3 as
Bridget now infected herself tries to
resist her Transformations while staying
in a rehab facility for teens Ginger
returns from Beyond the Grave appearing
to Bridget envisions with ghostly advice
filmed simultaneously with unleashed the
prequel ginger snaps back the beginning
offers a frontier variation on the
series
Stars Catherine Isabelle and Emily
Perkins return not as the ginger and
Bridget we know and love from the first
two films but as their 19th century
ancestors also named Ginger and Bridget
who find themselves or offend and lost
in the Canadian wilderness where
werewolves are assembled for
menstruation in the first film and
addiction in the second ginger snaps
back uses the genre's sturdy framework
to examine Canada's history of
colonialism and Indigenous extermination
even though the sequels weren't
particularly beloved they weren't
particularly hated either and they both
make for entertaining viewing nowadays
the tongue and decaying cheek Return of
the Living Dead series ran for three
bloody campy entries from 1985 to 1993
but just like a corpse exposed to the
military-grade poison gas trioxin the
series Rose from the grave more than a
decade later in 2005 two brand new
Return of the Living Dead sequels were
Unleashed upon the world putting a new
generation of teens in the path of
shambling corpses hungry for brains
necropolis the first of the new sequels
follows a group of high school students
whose friend is kidnapped by a nefarious
Corporation doing research on reanimated
bodies actor and frequent documentary
narrator Peter Coyote guest stars as the
doctor in charge of the experiment Andy
appears once again in the follow-up
Brave to the Grave what is all this for
isn't it obvious
world domination
what's everything ultimately for
taking place a year after the zombie
outbreak that ended necropolis raved to
the Grave follows the surviving high
schoolers now in college as a straight
canister of trioxin gets synthesized
into a party drug that starts turning
ravers into zombies Beyond using trioxin
as the source of the zombies Scourge the
films which wound up going straight to
the Sci-Fi channel bear little
resemblance to the first three lacking
their punk rock sensibility and love for
gooey goopy monsters
kiyoshi kurosawa's 2001 horror tragedy
pulse was part of a wave of
internationally acclaimed Japanese spine
tinglers released at the turn of the
Millennium naturally its inevitable
American remake directed by James and
zero and co-written by Wes Craven
arrived in theaters in 2006. it stars
Kristen Bell as a university student who
discovers that her boyfriend's death was
caused by a supernatural computer virus
that allows the dead to contact the
living through the internet like the
Japanese original the Remake has the
courage of its convictions ending on a
note of defeat as the virus takes hold
and the spirits of the Dead invade the
Earth the two pulsed sequels both
released in 2008 take place in a world
overrun with ghosts where the living now
exists as refugees in their own homes
pulse 2 afterlife which features a man
trying to protect his daughter from the
ghost of his vengeful ex-wife is nearly
unwatchable every scene appears to have
been filmed in front of a green screen
pulse 3 doesn't fare much better
visually or narratively this
post-apocalyptic take on the material
features a college student navigating
the new world and a young woman who
somehow discovers the world's last
working laptop you should probably click
away from these sequels if you ever run
into them I want to turn it off but
I can
Swedish crime writer Steve Larson's
posthumously released Millennium Trilogy
became a global sensation when the first
novel The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
was published in English in 2008 a
feature film adaptation from Swedish
production company yellow bird followed
in early 2009 along with adaptations of
the other two novels in the series The
Girl Who Played with Fire And The Girl
Who Kicked The Hornet's Nest later in
the year the complete Trilogy was given
a limited theatrical run in the United
States in 2010 by the distribution arm
of Chicago's music box theater
starring numi rupaz as hacker Elizabeth
Salander and Mikhail neek Beast as
Intrepid journalist Mikhail bomkeast the
films are a pitch black journey into the
descends of Sweden's past for
international audiences it's also
possibly their first taste of the
uniquely dark sexy and disturbing genre
of Scandinavian crime fiction director
Niels Arden uplift doesn't shy away from
the sexual violence that is endemic to
Larson's work the original Swedish title
of The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
translates to men who hate women after
all while the sequels may not have the
same visceral thrill as the first film
all three were released together to
paint a bleak portrait of a culture that
has yet to reckon with the rottenness at
its core
[Music]